hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts selecting a safe and
clean cannabis product parent's quest to
find the best medicine for his son
presented by Sebastian cot I am Judy
O'Rourke of lab rats and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinths
laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Sebastian caught I will now turn the
presentation over to him I will thank
you so much Judy for this introduction
and thank you everyone for joining us
today for this presentation very excited
to share with you a little bit of some
of the tips when I found were very
helpful for me when I was looking for
medical cannabis to get started with
medical cannabis with my son so we got
to go through a few different items
today then you are to look at and take
into consideration when you want to
start medical cannabis therapy first of
all what I want to start with is the
boring staff the disclaimer I know I
know but we got to do it pretty much if
you don't want to read it always say hey
then I am NOT a doctor and everything
I'm gonna tell you
evaluated by the FDA so please do not
take this as medical advice and get
anybody in trouble all right thank you
so much so little bit about me like I
just say I'm not a medical professional
I'm really just a dad and I am jagers
dad in the middle of the screen as a
picture of the side I'm sorry you can
see Jagger that's my little boy and
we'll talk more about Jagger in just a
few minutes but he's the reason why I'm
doing this
well I've been trying to help Jagger
I've been learning a lot of the
candidates and I been 35 by Americans
for safe access
I'm also founded with a few other
parents the group core geologists hope
this is a group of parents I was
responsible and still is responsible for
the medical cannabis legislation here in
the state of Georgia on the board of
director of the flowering Hope
Foundation and Board of Advisors of MD
herb all of those are volunteer only on
position I do not have any financial
interest or any financial gains from
cannabis and just really focus on
education and trying to help people and
mostly parents learn more about this
amazing plant so now let's talk about
Jagger that is my little boy Jagger has
a very rare form of Murakami or disease
or leaf disease this disease is very
progressive and unfortunately it's
terminal and if you get you diagnostic
before the age of two 95% of the kids
with fleas disease will not make a pass
with fourth birthday and Jagga
unfortunately get his diagnostic at age
one and he's been on hospice since then
when we were not able to pass a medical
cannabis bill in the state of Georgia in
2014 my wife Annette Jagger and I moved
to Colorado and became medical refugees
so we could get Jagger on medical
cannabis now it's much harder than its
own and then you know you can just put
on a slide in order to do that I
actually took a week of vacation I went
to Colorado and I did some research and
I looked at a few things and some of the
stuff I looked at and some of the things
that I learned from that trip we will
discuss in this presentation because
what is very important tips and advice
than any parent or patient can be Kim
can use we were in Colorado for 13
months and we came back home after 13
months mostly because Jagger breathing
with the altitude in Colorado was
getting worse but everything else was
doing much better on the picture on the
screen this is actually August 20th 2014
Jagger very first dose of CBD and we
started with CBD and we added other
cannabinoids down the road and today
Jagger is on CBD THC and CBN for sleep
but there is a picture a couple minutes
before we gave him his very first dose
after a really long difficult Trek to
Colorado from Georgia because six days
in a car because Jagger is not allowed
to fly due to his breathing issue anyhow
the cannabis has been great for Jagger
and Jagger just last September turn 7 so
he's not three and a half years passed
his life expectancy
he still has a terminal disease the
thing that's important to note is still
on hospice but for him and for our
family is all about quality of life and
know more about quality of other quality
of life you know it's all about the
quantity and not I'm sorry do that again
it's all about the quality of life and
not the quantity of life when you are an
artist patient you know your time is
limited so you want to make the best of
the time you have and you want to make
sure that the patient the kid or the
adult is living the best quality
possible with the less pain and this is
really what cannabis has done for us
he reduce jagger's seizures from
anywhere between 12 to 15 a day to three
or four a day and he reduces pain
tremendously Jagger has a lot of muscle
pain kids with mitochondrial disease can
build lactic acid in the muscle and it's
very painful you need to very bad
cramping Jagger is nonverbal is a
seven-year-old a body of seven year old
boy is like more than -3 months old so
he doesn't speak to us and tell us
what's wrong so it's always a big
guessing game with him now obviously
over time we get to know what's wrong
with him and we get to know his triggers
but it's really hard especially when he
has was muscle pain crisis because we
know exactly always know where this
happening so auspicious will give him
oxy
cotton and valium and methadone and
morphine we decided to try THC for both
and with the help of THC we reduced goes
muscle pain episodes by close to 90
percent and we are him now for over
three and a half years 100 percent off
oxy cotton and about 95 percent of
morphine so when we talk about this big
obvious crisis in this country it's very
important to keep in mind and cannabis
should be an option because he can help
a lot of the patient and kids like
Jagger but we did not get to here
overnight it took us a while we had to
learn a lot we had to do a lot of
research we have to play with dosing we
have to talk to doctors but mostly we
had to find a safe product and Bao was
are very difficult the reason why is
because we experiencing a green rush now
with CBD and cannabis to another extent
everybody is making a product
everybody's trying to sell you a product
and not every product is safe and clean
so this is why this presentation
hopefully is gonna do
you guys gotta take up some guideline
from this presentation on how to find a
safe product this presentation is not
going to go into our brand specific this
is not what we're here for
it just got to be very generic on what
are you looking for what kind of
questions you should ask when somebody
is trying to sell you a product it's
gonna be dividing to remain part the
first is to know the origin of your
product then is to know the product and
finally very important those are law
because not everything is legal
everywhere in this country and I know
this audience today is very coming from
all different states and part of the
country and not everybody has the same
legal protection or legal rights so this
is very important to keep in mind we're
gonna start with know the origin of the
product so nobody already knew the
product is first of all is who is
growing your cannabis plant is it grown
in the u.s. is it growing overseas is it
imported how is it grown and where is it
grown is it groaning a legal state so
you can have some protection and
hopefully you have a program set up and
it's actually a real company growing it
with protocols and guideline and
regulation or is it somebody growing a
the closet in the back of a yard in the
basement in an illegal state that does
make a big difference if it's good in
the US is it grow where is it grown in
the u.s. is a you get different strain
from different part California and
cannabis is very different from Colorado
cannabis for example can you visit the
growth that is very important for
parents sometimes when we not really
sure what the product come from you
could ask the grower if you could come
and visit no I'm gonna tell you not
every grower I gotta say yes come and
you are allowed to do that but it could
be taking as a little bit of a red flag
event very much against it again you
know you got a some rules on a
regulation could be different but for me
at least when I was able to visit the
girlfriend of the product we used for
Jagger when I was in Colorado that was a
huge peace of mind because I realized
this is not your college dealer you know
growing in his basement this is a very
well organized company with employees
and guideline and safety measures and
you know almost to the point oh you'll
be like a business already manufacturing
business with OSHA requirements it's um
it was very impressive to me when live
it was actually a real business so
that's one thing to keep in mind if you
can visit it is always better no you do
not always gonna be able to do that but
if you can is always better and then the
credential of the grower how long has it
been grow he or she's been growing IV
develop strain are they just really
putting seed on the ground and then you
know the nourishing women watering them
or are they actually doing development
to away doing some breeding OpenStack is
very important and usually you can find
that information by googling or asking
of our parents or our patients you know
in the community have you using XYZ
product do you know anything about X Y
Z's grow or you know which train is this
who grow best train there are resources
in in support group to be able to find
my information on the Internet so that's
about the grower in the growing of the
cannabis
one other thing too is is it go
indoor/outdoor it's very controversial a
lot of people will tell you one is
better than the other I don't look at it
like that I look at it
if it's go outdoor you have to be a
little bit more careful on some of the
lab report you go to need and we will
talk about lab report in the second part
of this presentation it's a little bit
easier to control the environment
obviously if you grow in a greenhouse
indoor you can still get some of the Sun
benefits in the greenhouse but you can
control may be the pest and the weather
a little bit better so that's something
to keep in mind but again it's not one
better than the other they both can make
very good in both indoor and outdoor can
make very good quality cannabis the
other thing I looked for and not just
because I have a business background so
I always look for that it's something
called vertical integration if you do
not know what her tikal integration mean
it pretty much means when the company is
in charge of every aspect of the product
development manufacturing all the way to
the cell so in the world of cannabis you
will be then the same person or company
is growing putting the seed of the clone
on the ground growing it taking care of
it during the growing period you know
with feeding it and watering it and
making sure it's okay harvesting it
drying it curing it if needed extracting
it and then putting it into bottle to go
out to a dispensary or set it directly
so the reason I like this is because you
get a much better control it's one
company overseeing every single aspect
of the process um I'm not saying when
you know some of the product which are
not vertically integrated are bad I'm
just saying you have more chance of
something going wrong if you have a
grower I said in my product to an
extractor that is sitting before work to
a butler to put in the bottles to be
sending that product to a distributor
I'm sitting back for a dispensary we got
four or five people touching that
product and you know putting the hands
on it and things can get much more
messed up when when you know with bowwe
however something to keep in mind is
that vertical integration is not legal
in every state in some states the person
extracting it cannot grow a different
type of licenses or the dispensary
setting and also not grow it so you
gotta keep that in mind when one
vertical integration give you a better
piece of
a new product is probably you know as
let's change to something go wrong I
mean it's not illegal everywhere now
let's talk about a product a little bit
that is where it can get very very
confusing and very tricky for parents
and patients because there are so many
different product in the market so we're
gonna break it down in a few things the
first thing we're gonna break it down to
is the extraction method now we could
honestly do a two hours presentation
just on this extraction method and the
different method and their pros and cons
and people won't agree and there will be
a lot of disagreement I'm gonna keep it
very simple and give you just the basic
on a few of them
ethanol extraction is by far the most
common cheaper and easiest one to do
that's the one when people can do in
Niger State you can do in your kitchen
that's the one that is very easy for
parents to do you can watch your very
close very short YouTube video and
figure it out so the advantage of a is
that is more accessible it's cheaper the
disadvantage of it is then first of all
you want to make sure when all the
alcohol is been purged using very high
very strong alcohol to do this to
extract all the cannabinoids and the
terpenes of the cannabis plant so you
want to make sure when you approached
about alcohol because the last thing you
want to give to your kid is a product
that is a lot of alcohol because
obviously our card is not good for the
liver especially in kids especially sick
kids
the other thing about alcohol it or add
to non extraction its run it pull out a
lot of the chlorophyll chroma field is
also a controversial subject because for
some people chlorophyll is very
beneficial chroma fields the reason why
the ethanol oil you would get if it's an
oil for example be more of a dark
greenish color that's an eternal
extraction and that's because of the
chlorophyll some people do not support
chlorophyll and given a lot of stomach
issues so they can have quality but some
people try and cross in and cross it
isn't helping them out so something to
keep in mind if you're using a product
is eternal extraction and you're
starting to see some stomach GI issues
why is maybe not your cannabis that
maybe you are you attack yeah your
eternal base oil so you could switch to
a different type of extraction and
usually take care of our problem
one of the most popular type of
extraction which is really gaining a lot
of steam in the market and the picture
on the on the slide right here is
actually a supercritical co2 extractor
its co2 extractions YouTube extraction
is using pressure to extract the product
so some people like to call this solvent
less because it doesn't have a solvent
like ethanol or butane or propane or say
it's using just steam and pressure to
get your cannabinoid utopians out co2
extraction the first generation of
extractor used to have a hard time
getting a lot of the terpene you will
lose some of the turbine for a chirping
when you extract it this way the new
machine are so good so the technology I
improved so much then you don't have to
worry about this if you have one of the
latest co2 extractor you do not lose
your terpenes you keep you get to keep
your terpenes and nobody can happy noise
but that was I know a concern of some
people in the earlier world of co2
extraction and then sometime you will
lose some of the terpenes because
they're boarding point it's very
different from the cannabinoid point but
that is not a concern anymore on the
brand new extractor butane and to a
point propane are also very popular
extraction method I'm for one not
somebody that want to give a butane
product to my son just because it scared
me off a little bit you know it's butan
it's propane it's not something you
should inhale or you know having your
body however that being say they are
very good product which are made with
regen and propane the key to generous
product is to get the correct lab report
and we will discuss the lab report in
just a few minutes it was a key on that
is to make sure an expert and you have
no residual solvents 0 ppm or part per
million of mutant left the problem is a
lot of people are doing butane or
propane extraction
you know how the technology and the lab
to be able to go to a hundred percent
clean butane product in 0 ppm so a lot
of the times the butane product on the
market you will have some residue or
solvent within you 10 and that's
obviously not very good so if you can
find a clean butane prop product and you
have the lab report to show it mutant
can be very beneficial
the last one I want to discuss is xane
and to a point nafta this is all the way
to do things
this is the beginning of the Rick
Simpson oil people using NAFTA and XM to
you know to extract product a lot of the
isolate product you see in the market
when somebody telling you this is 99.9%
pure CBD or pure THC a lot of us product
I extract it with hexane I am NOT a fan
of XM because xn is actually very
dangerous and can cause cancer and some
people so as a rule of thumb I will
always stay away from an excellent
product you will see like I say more
excellent product in the what we call
the isolate world not the full-spectrum
product but this pure CBD pth-tt product
a lot of am I using xane and I would
stay away from this product mostly for
the reason of the extraction method now
if we talking about carrier oil if we're
talking about oil there are different
ways the carrier oil is pretty much as a
way is the oil by you mixing with your
CBD or THC or
any cannabis concentrate you're mixing
that together the reason you're mixing
it is to make it easier to those you
diluting the product as a concentrate
because it's very hard to do those
concentrate concentrate is often very
thick and gooey product and you can just
be like I need 0.2 milliliter of that
it's very difficult to do so by mixing
it with an oil it make it much easier to
do it especially for the kids someone's
very popular one probably the most
popular one is MCG slash coconut oil
mcg is stand for medium chain
triglyceride is actually a coconut oil
with the lauric acid remove so it's a
manufacture product but it's the liquid
and that's what a lot of people like
it's liquid coconut oil now um one of
the big benefits of coconut oil is a
lowering acid you won't get that I'm the
MCT so just keep that in mind but a lot
of people like the MCG because a lot of
kids like the taste of it you kind of
mask the taste of of the cannabis
sometimes their horrific tones of
cannabis suppliers are so very popular
once a flower is good because he has a
very long shelf life and it's
antimicrobial so any product made with
sapphire can use
last keep a little bit longer all these
voices are so very good one because very
few people are averaging to olive oil so
whatever is is is a popular choice only
boy however does not keep as long and
after a few months can go rancid so you
really have to keep an eye on your olive
oil products using olive oil and you
know using it very quickly now when
you're looking at vape pain and
vaporizing oil a lot of them and make
with providing like or or what we call
PG for short that are the kind when I
will stay 100% away from and the reason
for that is then we are study now
showing been when you heat up PG you can
call you can burn into other chemicals
that can cause cancer so that can be
very dangerous
so if vaping is your favorite admission
route or your cannabis usually we talk
more about adult while you know dating
for kids is very controversial so we are
talking about adult I try to find a
product that is you either using a
vegetable glycerin or pure cannabis oil
but does not have a PG in it
unfortunately is a great majority of
vape pain oil on the market today a PG
base and that's something I would stay
away from so let's get to the really big
important part of this presentation and
lab testing we've got lab testing you
really cannot make the decision on what
product is good what product is not good
it's unfortunately not as simple as it
should be first of all a lot of
companies have their own machine to test
as a product for development for rnd
the problem with that is sometimes they
try to give you hose tests as your lab
tests no I am NOT saying my company our
taking the test and you know forging it
I'm saying that it's been done
unfortunately I'm not saying everybody's
doing it but it's been done and I'm
saying when it's often better to make
sure you have a third party lab a lab or
a test report from a lab but just as
data is not associated with affiliated
with any of the manufacturer or people
sitting in the oil
both just differ from state to state in
some state there is no labs in some
state they can only take product to test
from dispensaries and up from parents so
you have to find your own lab you're in
your own state why is a law regarding
laboratory testing of cannabis
unfortunately it's not not all states
are created equal and in state like
California for example it's much much
easier get your product tested than in
state even like Colorado or or throw it
at for example what you can do if you
want to make sure is when you find when
you get the lab and I'll show you in a
few minutes some central lab report you
will have the name of the lab in most of
them and you will have a number it's
totally okay and actually recommended
the first time at least when you buy a
new product to call my lab and say hi my
name is you know Sebastian and I just
bought this all for my son Jagger and I
see that you tested the lab this is a
lab report and if this is all for XYZ
CBD I just want to verify did you test
that and my lab report showing it's 20
milligrams per milliliter can you
confirm that lab should be able to tell
you that so much a nice piece of mind if
you want to make sure when the lab
report is not forged for example if for
some reason you not really sure what's
going on it's always good to verify the
first time some of the California lab
put a QC code without the code you can
take your numbers little funky square
and you can take a picture of on your
phone and you take you somewhere we're
not good to you can take a picture of
that on your lab record and this should
take you to the lab and you can verify
it that way another thing which is very
important to know is what kind of
machines the labs are using again
now every labs are created equal right
now HPRC which is ultra performance
liquid chromatography or you HPLC ultra
performance as a favorite machine but
ones are very expensive the picture on
the presentation is actually HPLC
machine because I'm not chips not
everybody can happen so all the way to
do it is with a GC or gas chromatography
machine so problem with that and this is
a reason why you need to ask the right
question in the lab ask
especially when you come down to potency
testing ask them which machine be using
for that if it tell you by using a GC or
gas chromatography machine by is a red
flag and the reason for that is then
when the sample grow to go through the
GC machine you actually get heated up um
when your cannabis is heated
if you get heated to a certain
temperature you thta can transform and
decarboxylated to THC right so if you
get your potency testing and it's done
on a GC machine very often you could
actually show you when he has more THC
than it really does and less THC a when
it does because of the heating up
process going to the Machine of the
sample this is why at least for your
potency you really want an HPLC test or
you HPLC test result the last thing to
know about the lab is you can check the
credential again and I'm gonna repeat
that a lot not every states are created
equal in some state they are simply no
lab testing certification but in some
state they can have ISO certification
they can have state certification so you
want to check with the lab and ask them
on this certification and just give them
a call and say are you certified what
are you creating show or you can look
online on their website those are
usually posted now let's talk a little
bit more about the kind of specific kind
of labs when you're looking for there
are a lot of labs tests but it is a top
six which are the most important potency
microbial within your solvent heavy
metal pesticide and terpenes we are now
going to look at each one of those
individually and explain why they are
important and how do you read one of
those tests let's start with potency you
can not those accurately those cannabis
for kids or any patient if you do not
have a potency lab report that is a lab
before bicycle to tell you how many
milligrams of THC per milliliter is in
your bottle of oil for example or CBD is
going to show you all the cannabinoid
which are in the product if you look as
a
you see a pie chart and the different
colors out the different can be no on
this sample assure you so you actually
need ways to be able to test you need
ways to be able to keep track of what's
working and not working maybe why is
making the difference for your kid it's
really not the CBD but it's the CBG this
one strain has a little bit more CBD
than this one oh it's a cbc is helping
with a brain recovery and by one strain
you know as more than the other ones so
secondary cannabinoids are so very
important and they should be listed in
your potency testing lab before so this
is why it's important you must have it
two doors and you must have it you know
really what you're giving your kid and
that can help you when you're looking a
different strain down the road i can
really help you to narrow down what's
working and what's not working for you
the second one which to me is one of the
most important is a microbial test this
is a sample from a steeping in new
mexico and this is very important
because kid like jagger for example with
auto immune system issue if I were to
give him a a cannabis product that has
bacteria of fungus or a coli or
Salmonella I can make things much much
worse really quickly even on a healthy
person you shouldn't be giving
Salmonella or yeast or mold so those are
microbial testing are very important
because let's face it
cannabis is a plant some time it grows
outside some time it grows in a
greenhouse it's a plant if you can have
Salmonella on broccoli or spinach when
you buy in a grocery store or ecoli
trust me you can have it on a Canada
student so it's very important to know
my new product is safe and clean
sometimes the product can take a little
bit of time to get this result because
if they find something in the initial
taste test they will actually grow into
a pigeon a petri dish sorry for up to
seven days to see if the bacteria is
growing there so it could take a while
to get this report back but it's a very
important report to make sure when
you're eating a safe clean product your
kid and at the end of the day the
emphasis of this presentation the
emphasis of starting cannabis therapy
for your kid is to help not to hurt and
in order to help you want to make sure
you're getting a clean product
adding a microbial test resort it's a
very very important step in that
direction
resilient solvent is very important as
well we discussed those depending on the
extraction method if you know your
product is met with co2 extraction is
not such an important test to get
because you will have any solvent if you
smelt with ethanol on alcohol it's very
important on the slide right there is
actually a product that has a cow
alcohol extraction ethanol extraction I
wasn't not purged correctly and you can
see the big spike in the reddish pinkish
color you can see that big spike and
that's mean when he has edge no it's
usually measure in ppm which stands for
part per million if you have let's be
honest if you have a really low ppm is
you know 5 10 ppm is probably going to
be okay on the ethanol I like to see
zero to be honest on non detected
sometimes the Machine doesn't go to zero
but it goes to very low and it doesn't
say a number of ways to non detect a or
Andy is fine to again a little tiny bit
of ethanol could be okay but anything
like xane or propane or butane vas
should be absolutely zero if it's not
it's not a safe product and it's not
something I would give to especially not
to a kid or sick person
heavy metal body coming a problem mostly
with outdoor grown cannabis the reason
or hands CBD so reason for is called
something called arm bioremediation and
the hemp plant and to a point the
cannabis plant because they both the
same family of plant they like to draw
toxin out of the ground they are you
explains I used to clean up soil by was
spoil with a spray of oil or nuclear
product or things like this they use
hemp plant or cannabis plant to grows to
clean the soil but that mean man the
plant is taking everything of the soil
that mean man in some instances if he's
grown outdoor in a salt and you don't
know you could have lead arsenic or
mercury you know all over on every metal
in your product now I'd like to see zero
on all of us but there is lead
almost everything and a little bit of
arsenic in your rice and your eating
they are very low level of contaminated
contamination so it's important to know
the limit if you have a lab resort and
you saw a tiny bit of lead like this one
on the example show 0.006 is totally
fine that is way less than the safe
amount which is 0.005 so this is you
know a tiny bit it's a trace amount
probably the same thing you get in your
rice and why is okay but again it's very
important to get that test and to know
this is very important it's with the
outdoor grown plant and with the Prada
back come from oversea and fortunately
as this Green Rush is booming
people are trying at times to pass very
subpar product on to the patient and
sometimes what companies are doing is
been buying taste of CBD hemp paste from
China which is a byproduct of when they
extracted to make rope or clothing is a
byproduct it's like a waste but it's
going to a paste and they ship it to the
US some companies are buying it running
into a couple of filters which is
definitely not enough and mixing with
oil and sending you at as a CBD product
which add up to very often being really
cheap so they're our gimmick is run as a
cheap product you can try CBD uh this is
where I need a lab report and especially
in that case a heavy-metal lab report
because both a company and most product
are very often contaminated with lead
and arsenic so again if you know hundred
percent sure the origin if you don't
know if it's grown indoor into control
soul environment asked for a heavy metal
test pesticide um pesticide used to not
be a problem but unfortunately again as
we are now going into this green rush
and everybody wants to put product in
the market and the growers I have a lot
of pressure on them to grow as many
cannabis plant as fast as possible there
some of them are starting to use
pesticide uh and by is very bad but it's
very bad because obviously pesticide can
are very dangerous long term side
effects especially on kids that have
immune system issues
on anybody it's not good to eat
pesticide and you know again the growers
are trying to get the product of the
market and they have whitefly or they
had you know something on the plant and
this guy can lose all my crop I gotta
take care of it and I'm gonna spray that
and it will be fine it's not gonna be
fine they are natural way to take care
of pesticide but unfortunately those
cost more money and sometimes take a
little bit more time and some of the
unscrupulous growers but are not there
to help the patient we're really just to
make money might be using pesticide
which are not approved advised been seen
a lot lately with the record have been a
lot of recall especially in steak at
Colorado a lot of products were recalled
and taking of the chefs because the
tested positive for some very dangerous
pesticide now one thing to keep in mind
about cannabis and it's about USDA
Organic certification because the
cannabis plant itself is still a
Schedule one substance in the controlled
substance act misty federally illegal in
the US there is no USDA Organic
certification on cannabis unfortunately
receive a aware I would be a nice peace
of mind because you can now use
pesticide or anything like that to get
you USDA Organic certification however
on the hand plant that is used to make
CBD there is a USDA Organic
certification very few company have them
but you can always look for it you can
google it and there's a handful of even
lessen that company that I have the USDA
Organic certification on that am plant
it's not the final all product because
that's again not possible but each arms
actually crop itself so that will give
you a big peace of mind because you know
that to get a certification they have to
go to a very very long process and they
are subject to surprise test and
inspection and visits they cannot use
any kind of pesticide they have to be
grown in a certain closed environment so
if you are looking for CBD product look
for USDA Organic certification I will
give you a nice piece of mine
unfortunately by is not a very board on
cannabis product as of today
and finally the last lab result I wanna
talk about is terpene job it's a fairly
new field turbines are kind of the
essential oil
of the plant of the cannabis plant
turbine as a plant level has two main
function one is to attract pollinators
like bees to make sure the plan to
reproduce and the second is to protect
the plant from predators by emitting
some kind of smell that would be you
know repulsive to small animals or
insects if I want to eat the plant if
you use essential oil in your life any
kind of essential oil you use Terrapins
that's pretty much what it is
terpenes is not to be ingesting it
neither the board everywhere
it used to be just really a California
centric thing it is slowly gaining
ground and going to different state it
seemed much much easier to get chirping
information in California than anywhere
else in Colorado for example it's almost
impossible to get it in some other state
on the East Coast it's very difficult so
again the West Coast California
Washington State Oregon much gives you
to get chopping profile the reason
terpenes are important is because that
could hold the key on why the product is
working or not working you know somebody
might be like oh I tried this XYZ CBD
and it's really not working for my kid
but I try
ABC CBD and or XYZ SVD and it's working
for my kid but they both CBD they both
have the kind of the same CBD
concentration well you got a look at the
secondary cannabinoid like we talked
about CB g CB n the cbc things like that
but you start to look as a chirping
maybe it's because he has a lot of line
a little bit maybe because yes a lot of
mersin this is why it's working or maybe
it's because he has beta carrier filing
this is why it's working
so as we trying to really pin down
what's working and as we trying as
parent and patient to really see what's
helping us adding a chirping profile on
the product is very helpful because he
could help us in that quest to find the
absolute best product unfortunately it
would take some time as far as trial and
error based if not a lot of dr. around I
can help you with cannabis so it puts
the almond on the parent and the patient
so keep good notes on what's working and
what not working which strain is helping
which train is not helping and if you
are lucky enough or fortunate
Travie chirping profile you can maybe
hopefully after a few different strain
its your correlation of a strain with
disturbing and high quality seems to
help you or hurt you depending on you
know the resort you've seen so champion
profile is very new it's important I
think it's a future of personalized
cannabis therapy so hopefully we're
gonna see more and more terpene testing
available in more and more states so
cannabis is very safe everybody knows
that but there are still things that can
happen with cannabis and I think it
would be at this you know it would be
very important for me to tell you what
can happen so what are some of the side
effect or safety concern you could get
when you start medical cannabis therapy
if you do not have a microbial test
resort and you don't know where you can
have is coming from it's very possible
when you can get a bacterial or fungal
infection for the cannabis which again
explain why you should really get a
microbial test result on your cannabis
you can be sleepy by this very common
side effect it usually goes away after a
few days but it's not unusual for people
to be sleepy to you're tired when they
start cannabis therapy even just CBD by
you she goes away for after a few days
it doesn't go away you just back down on
your dose a little bit and usually that
take care of it
you could have allergy that could cause
in diarrhea or any GI issue by is
usually not an allergy that will come
from the cannabis itself
I don't know anybody elegy to cannabis
not to see doesn't exist
I just don't know anybody in all the
people I'm talking to a patient and
parents I talk to it's more than likely
coming from the carrier oil maybe mcg or
doesn't agree with stomach maybe
safflower give your reflux so if you're
starting to see some GI issues shortly
after starting you can be starving
it's more of a knack is a carrier oil
and then hopefully um you have a choice
of carrier oil where you bind your
product you can just switch maybe from
coconut to safflower from olive oil to
MCG or so on agitation and paranoia it's
a very rare which is possible by is
usually a sign when you are now using
the right strain and unfortunately I
mean
you have to do more trial and errors but
that usually a sign that the strain were
using is not ideal for your condition
the most important possible side effect
is interaction with medication a lot of
the medication you takes out process to
what we call the p450 liver enzyme and
so is cannabis the reason this is
important is because cannabis itself is
not going to do anything or change
anything to itself but it can increase
or decrease level of medication in your
blood so advice to take is even if you
are taking any kind of medication by our
process to the p450 liver enzyme and the
way to know that is you can Google your
medication and p450 liver and I'm number
two things you need to do number one you
need to try to get a baseline blood
serum level of us medication this is
just a simple blood test I will tell you
the level of medication new body of Bose
medication and the concentration you're
seeing in your blood after you start can
at least two weeks or three weeks after
you start get another test compared to
your baseline see if is doing anything
then after a few months do another one
and if you don't see any interaction any
change in the concentration you are okay
but Kennedy it can increase level of
medication without you knowing so we can
actually get you to a toxic level of
medication or we can decrease it without
you knowing so you're giving your
medication every day but it's almost
kinda like going to a win this is most
often seen with seizures medication and
that can be a problem because all the
sudden now you're starting this cannabis
therapy may supposed to help and it
works for a few days and then you stop
working and you're like what's going on
that could be when he was working in
combination with you anti-seizure
medication but now he's anti-seizure
medication level is too high or too low
and it's causing issues so space it out
any
p450 met in cannabis should be spaced
out like two hours when you give it to
it when you give it to the patient to
the kid and get a blood serum level
before starting and then after a few
weeks in a few months
you see if interaction and finally the
last thing I will talk to you on the
product is about the therapeutic index
in the safety of cannabis index is a
combination of ld50 of eg 50 and let me
explain very quickly bodies
ld50 sent for lethal dose so in a lab
environment it will take some mice for
example and of any medication they will
give a mice a dose of medication I will
keep increasing the dose until they kill
half of the population of the mice
I want those that half of the population
of the mice die that is your little
those a defect 50 is your effective dose
same concept keep giving medication our
what those you see some kind of
beneficial effect on the mice you take
the first number divided by the second
one give you an end X the higher the
number the safer the medication and
cannabis is 40,000 to one making him one
of the safest substance on Earth for
example morphine valium fentanyl all of
those other index of less than hundred
to one very dangerous both opiates
cannabis is 40 dozen to one making it
much much safer even those alternative
so now when we talk about product we
talk about the grower we talk about the
product you know actually read aloud
report let's talk about the last point
in our presentation which is a law and
why is very important because that
differ from places where you are living
we have 30 states plus Washington DC
right now I have full medical cannabis
program but however does not mean when
they are creating equal some of our
states are dispensaries some are working
on this getting dispensary some student
imitations on what you can get at your
dispensary but all of those states have
some kind of access either today or in
the future for the state that just
passed bill 16 states have limited
program and that is really wide you can
go from actually I've access state
solutions at Virginia we just passed
this or Missouri have limited very
limited program of limited condition but
this in a limit on THC or on delivery
may be no smoking or no live plant or no
dry flower but most states change from
five percent THC limiting Georgia to 0.3
percent in Utah so it's very wide range
the problem is at the end of the days
and cannabis is to just give you one
substance under the controlled substance
act now it doesn't make any sense
everybody hopefully watching this today
understand banned the government
classification of Kennedy says that Skid
Row 1 is a joke
and you should not happen a Schedule one
substance definition is venya has no
medical benefit and yet high potential
for abuse we know for a fact then before
those things I'm not true when it comes
down to cannabis but the government
doesn't want to take it off schedule one
Kennedy says no room to be on schedule
one mascara one maker then unfortunately
is not illegal federally so every states
after the law and depending where you
live you may or may not ask access to
cannabis because of that it's also an
pitting on a lot of the research we can
do so it's very important to talk to you
ladies later when you do that and always
ask them to that cannabis off of
Schedule one and actually cannabis to
not even be on any schedule but anything
would be better than one on anyhow yes
five schedule but fortunately one day
and hopefully one day we will be totally
off the controlled substance act some
states have registry actually most
states have registry on a medical
cannabis site you do not need a registry
when you go to a recreational dispensary
is working with medical cannabis you
need a registry that means when you went
to see a doctor and when you get you get
a card that was signed by your doctor
and then you have one of the condition
that qualify in your state every state
is different some state like California
the doctor can decide some state like
North Carolina it's only for seizures
patient so every state again is
different so reason when it's good to
get the card is because even if you say
I don't need a card I have no dispensary
why do I need a car it's important
because they offer you protection
especially when you talk about children
maybe it lets you give the oil in the
hospital setting or maybe you protect
you if child services come to the
hospital when you charge that meeting
say why did you son tested positive for
THC be like because it's a medical
cannabis patient here's my card so it's
very important to register for the car
in most states they are fairly
affordable and the last for a year or
two and you just give you back extra
little piece of mind especially if
you're running into issue with doctors
and hospital and if your kid he or she
being admitted to the hospital
it's very nice peace of mind to have and
finally we are going to finish with a
nice visual of the map so remember we
talked about 30 states and DC both of
the states in green both states have
full medical program no restriction on
THC and at some point we have access not
every one of them like Louisiana Ohio
Pennsylvania we just passed their bill
so we don't have access yet but we are
working on getting access to setting it
up the red state like Georgia South
Carolina Alabama all over the place on
the percentage of THC on the access most
of them don't have any access except
from Missouri and Virginia eventually
but there's no access in any other state
easy access the percentage of THC and
why is legal vary from state to state
some is only oil some is orden Eddy
board some is topical some is actually
no vaping no smoking at all and then you
got four states in blue which are the
four stage in the country there's
nothing not even what we call a CBD or
low THC law they absolutely have nothing
everything is illegal to them except you
know what could be portrayed as legal
the hemp oil under the farm bill at the
federal level but even then most states
frown upon that and are very very
closed-minded when you come down to
cannabis so the best advice if you live
in any other state is especially if you
live in a in a red states or blue state
find out what's legal in your states
before using cannabis therapy for not
have to get on the registry Faneuil was
qualified and final doctor based willing
to sign on fully it's your doctor so it
makes things a lot easier conversation a
lot easier but sometime you might have
to go to a different doctor just to get
your card sign well you know I hope you
guys learned a lot today I hope you guys
know how to select a clean safe cannabis
product now I'm gonna give you a little
of my contact information and then we
have a tiny bit of time so I like to
take some questions if we have you know
if we have some questions I'll be more
than happy to try to answer any question
we have and again my name is Sebastian
and you can email me a Sebastian at
firing of the CEO not comes your or
Colorado
and I would be very happy to answer any
question and help you in your cannabis
journey well thank you and let's take
some question Thank You Sebastian for
that informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button will answer as
many questions as we have time for let's
get started our first question is if I
find a clean tested product in another
state can I just have it shipped to me
if I have a medical cannabis card in my
state that's a great question
unfortunately the short answer is no
especially if it's a product that has
more than 0.3% of THC it's a product
that has less than 0.3% of THD then you
are okay because you would be consider
him under the 2014 farm bill so while
it's still a great legal area most
products ship every day without any
problem if you need a product that has
more THC than that it does not matter if
you have a card in your state it's
illegal to ship any product with more
than 0.3% THC anywhere in the US so
unfortunately the answer to that is no
you would not be able to get that ship
regardless of your legal status in your
state well thank you for that
if a company cannot provide lab reports
is the product still okay to use for my
head no I would I'm gonna tell you now
they are enough products on the market
today that offer full lab reports move
on find another product you know if the
reason we don't have a lab report is
because it says the lab and it's gotta
be tested it's coming in the next couple
days Ben wait absolutely if it's because
they can afford it or you say oh you
don't need to be these tests it's a good
product no no no that you can village
people anymore unfortunately too many
people are getting into this industry
trying to make money not caring about
their patients and so you want a lab
report and if the product man you select
your you think selected does not have a
lab report
move on there are a lot of other
products in our testing than you can
find thank you we have time for one more
question can hemp CBD oil be imported
from another country and safe to use is
a very excellent question ah yes you can
be imported from our country even the
law is actually a bit different but yes
we can and to me would be the same thing
uh you know it would be get the lab
report come from another country that's
fine but get the lab report with it and
if he has a lab report and use a tested
product and show then it's clean product
and you can verify the labs then you
could use it that being say let's just
you know the ultra American for one
second here and seven we have a lot of
really high quality product in this
country California Colorado a lot of the
other states especially when you're
talking about him you know
anonymous product from our country will
have a USDA Organic certification and a
few product from the US have it so my
first choice personally it would be to
look for a usda organic certified
american grown product that being say if
your product come from a different
country and it's lab tested there is
nothing wrong with it you can use it
thank you i would like to once again
thank sebastian [ __ ] for his
presentation would also like to thank
Leopards for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go i want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through June 29 2018 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting me know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye